how desperate are things now for people
living
in lebanon extremely desperate sophie as
you know
we have food inflation at 250 percent
the lira has devalued
we were at 1500 we're at 8 000
this is unbearable to the normal which
means the purchasing power of
the normal lebanese have uh fell
around eightfold tenfold and god knows
where where we're gonna go from here
definitely if the situation is that
there are you know if we don't remedy
the situation and move
and expedite uh and take
drastic measures to remember the
situation it's only gonna get worse so
yes the economic
the the savings of people has been wiped
out uh
moody's has downgraded lebanon to see
which is the lowest downgrade
uh i mean the situation could really get
worse we are in inflation
uh spiral venezuelan type inflation so
it's the situation is extremely bad yes
and we've seen of course those protests
near the parliament
you of course were saying earlier that
you don't want to run for
you know the presidency or the prime
minister or role but you're still seen
as a
figure of the opposition i guess we
should uh point out
but how much anger do you think there is
towards politicians right now in lebanon
the the the the people under underground
they have
all the right to be angry sophie it's
their total right people have lost their
family
members uh i have my colleagues uh
unfortunately
they are safe but some members in in my
in within my colleagues could not make
it
so people have all the right to be anger
i would call for calm
but at the end of the day they are
entitled this
is a democracy and they are entitled we
i mean i fully understand their anger
but at the end i'm not a person i've
never believed in
in in violence uh but it's fully
understandable
the anger they're living in it's been
accumulating and accumulating and
accumulating
we cannot stay in a situation where
one one section is is controlling
everything this is this is
unbearable we are in an unbearable
situation
we we cannot do this on our own uh to me
we have to get our act together we have
to move forward as lebanese i believe in
the lebanese i believe in hope i believe
in the resilience
uh as you know i was barely once year
one year old
uh i've been i lived in africa uh
high school i was raised there
unfortunately i was when when
hariri died to me uh i truly believe
in in in the resilience and the
perseverance of the lebanese so
if if something when we need we need to
to be resilient
we were able to get out of it lebanon
was in a complete complete utter
disruption after the
the uh as you know very well the
uh civil war and we were able to get our
to get out of it we
if we were able to do that then we can
do it now
again but at the end we have we have to
be resilient we have to believe in
in ourselves as lebanese and and try to
move forward of course get our act
together
i've connected i've been in contact with
the patriarch
and he's i believe in the neutrality i
fully
i fully support his view on neutrality
but as you know
uh lebanon in 2005 we were we were
almost there sophie and you know that
very well
the lebanon was we wanted to go from a
country
from a country to a unified nation we
couldn't
god bless the sorority has been
assassinated hopefully
that tribunal will shed light to this uh
next week
but what we want is to get out of this
confession
i would add to the unity to the
directority
uh issue is we have to get out of con
from this confessional uh
stat status and go and make lebanon a
full democracy
just listening to you talk i've got to
ask
why do you not want to run for election
because it's not about me it's bigger
than this sophie today the the company
it is about leaders as well
leaders do matter why do you not want to
run
because each one has its own ways you
know people are different you you so if
you like to help your own way i like to
help in my own way
we have choice this is the beauty of
life we we have to have we have to
respect this our choice
you know i will i will serve my nation
the best way possible
but to run in my like i give you an
example my father believes in education
i believe in jobs
that that doesn't mean he he's right or
wrong or i'm right or wrong but each one
has his own way
i believe i can help in the best way i
can by
i will serve my my country the best way
possible but right now
sophie the situation is we need to mourn
we have 154 people dead i'm appalled by
the
horrific event i'm mourning with them
uh i whatever i can do i can help uh
but at the end of the day i'm i'm coping
with the situation this
this to me is inconceivable sophie i
mean 15 years i haven't been into into
anything that is regarding politics
this just happened now and and i'm
barely coping with events one after the
other
like what happened 72 hours ago
so at the end of the day we we we will
help the best way but i will do my
utmost to help i will do my utmost to
her
okay bahar hiroi thank you very much for
being on the program this evening thank
you
thank you for having me